Alright baby,
let's do this thing.
Coffee on a Tuesday and block 39,
so I know it's not good to talk about
politics or religion in polite
conversation,
but flame wars be damned.
I'm doing it.
I had quite a wonderful time last
Thursday watching the vice presidential
debate.
It was a hoot and holler and stripped to
the waist,
bare knuckle boxing match,
twix,
Joey Mac and the spell poindexter.
The debate range from Libya to Iran to
Medicare to taxes to abortion and Martha
Raddatz was wonderful indeed and though
she held the debate by the scruff of its
neck,
she was not opposed to letting the
opponents slug it out when it came to
blows because that's what they went
there to do.
That's democracy.
Let's take a look at one exchange that
interested me.
I am.
I'm not allowed to show letters,
but go on our website.
He sent me two letters saying,
by the way,
can you send me some stimulus money for
companies here in the State of
Wisconsin?
We sent millions of dollars.
You know why he said it asked for
stimulus.
By the way,
on two occasions we,
we,
we advocated for
constituents who are applying for grants
now,
Ryan and the Romney,
Ryan ticket and the House Republican
Caucus and Senate Republicans and
Republicans generally have spent a lot
of time decrying the efficacy of the
recovery act called by many the stimulus
package.
They spend a lot of time saying how this
didn't work,
how it failed,
and they're repetitive.
Persistence in this matter has worked
out pretty well for them considering
that this huge,
some would say signature piece of
legislation from the Obama
administration is barely ever talked
about by the administration itself,
but as the exchange showed spelled
poindexters own requests for stimulus
funds for his state seems to contradict
his party's assertion that the stimulus
did nothing for small businesses.
In fact,
the stimulus achieved a whole host of
things including getting a two drowning
states tax cuts for middle income
Americans grants for schools based on
performance.
It paved the way for a smart grid.
It accelerated the process of digitizing
health records.
It's spent money on homelessness.
Prevention on infrastructure upgraded
236 miles of flood control levees,
350 military base,
850 wastewater systems and 400,000
public housing apartments.
It helped bring broadband internet too
far out communities and it invested in
future technologies and fledgling
industries.
An example of both is green energy now.
This in particular has Paul Ryan in a
tizzy $90,000,000,000
in green pork to campaign contributors
and special interest groups like he
himself urge Labor Secretary Hilda Solis
to fund a green jobs training program in
Wisconsin.
Green energy is a special favorite of
mine when it comes to the recovery act
because at the end of the Bush
administration,
that sector was on the edge about to
die.
Solar companies,
wind companies,
biofuel companies,
we're ready to move their businesses to
other places in the world because in
America the money just wasn't there.
In just the decade before Obama took
office,
our share in global solar production and
deployment fell from 40 percent to eight
percent.
The recovery acts investment in Green
Tech is a great example of how a
government should seek to affect change
without the billions of dollars in
grants from the stimulus.
Green energy companies were dead in the
water compared to dirty energy.
Companies whose costs from huge scale
allowed them to produce at a much
cheaper and more competitive rate,
not to mention the billions in subsidies
dirty was and is getting from the
government already.
Green Tech needed help to bridge what's
called the valley of death.
That period of time for startups when
they acquire lots of debt,
building their product and achieving the
economies of scale necessary to make
that business profitable.
Green Tech was dying because each of its
various technologies was too young or
too risky for private investors who
could make easier money on other things.
Some will tell you that government
investment like the $90,000,000,000,
that green tech guide in the stimulus
package is bad because it crowds out
private investment in 2009 at the height
of the recession when capital money was
nowhere.
The crowding out argument doesn't really
hold water.
The recovery act actually crowded in
private investment by helping new
technologies,
solar,
wind,
battery,
biofuel bridge,
the valley of death,
making the opportunity sexier.
Solar was dying.
Now it's one of the fastest growing
industries in the country and if we just
take a look at Romney's old five point
plan here,
we'll see.
Oh yes.
Second we'll give our fellow citizens
the skills they need for the jobs of
today and the careers are tomorrow.
Jobs of tomorrow check.
So if you wanna learn more about the
recovery act,
I highly,
highly,
highly recommend you read Michael
Grunwald new book,
the new new deal.
It should be required reading for anyone
who is going to vote next month.
It's got pictures in it to look.
Look,
look,
it's Joe Biden and President Obama were
just hanging out,
hanging out.
But.